Crowd: Good Morning Hank it's Tuesday!
John: So Hank, I've just finished Fox's tour
for The Fault in Our Stars movie
John [voice over]: featuring Shailene Woodley,
Ansel Elgort, and Nat Wolff, pictured here
dancing, getting psyched up for the show.
The tour started in Miami where everyone dramatically
underestimated how many people would show
up which led to big A/V problems and crowd
control and generally I'm just very sorry.
But lessons were learned and everyone was
much better prepared in Cleveland where several
thousand people wanted to say hello to you,
Hank.
Crowd: Good morning Hank [indistinct cheering]
John [voice over]: We were also reunited with
some of our friends who played members of
the support group in the movie, all of whom
have lived with cancer.
And we got to hang with YouTuber Evelina Barry
who was our awesome co-host on the tour.
John: Awww, it's the smile that slayed a thousand
hearts.
Nat: *chuckling*
John: And Nat Wolff
John [voiceover]: Had to get up very early
the next morning to get my hair and makeup
done.
It takes a lot of work to wrangle the puff.
And then I had many, many hours of interviews.
John: Hank, press junket interviews are weird
'cuz you talk to a new TV interviewer person
every five minutes for, like, hours.
And it's really hard to talk meaningfully
about, like, anying because 1) you only have
five minutes and 2) they have to get their
quotes and 3) you've been asked the same question
a thousand times before and 4) I was really
worried about saying something stupid and/or
insensitive.
Also, 5) I knew if they made me keep talking
I would eventually get the husky voice and
I have.
Anyways, I realize I am winning like an Olympic
gold medal for the first-worldiest first-world
problems.
My point is that it was hard to engage.
On the upside sometimes we got goodie bags
with treats in them.
Hank the best part about being on tour with
someone who doesn't eat processed food is
that you get Shailene Woodley's GooGoo clusters.
John [voiceover]: Anyway, then we went to
Nashville, a lovely town, where there was
this red carpet like thing and lots of people
to sign for, which is great, but also weird
because I would like to stop and talk to them
and have as near a normal interaction as possible
given the circumstances, but there were these
large men on both sides of me pushing me along
and lots of screaming and just in general
the whole situation was no more conducive
to meaningful conversation than press junkets.
Then I did a few red carpet interviews- again,
difficult to feel connected to the world slash
the actual people in it.
And then we went inside where Nat and Alex
Wolff were playing a concert.
Shailene and I lay down on the floor and peeked
under the curtain to watch.
Also, there were quite a lot of people there
who wanted to say hi to you.
Crowd: Good Morning Hank it's Tuesday.
John [voice over]: Next morning, more hair,
more makeup, and many more hours of press
before going to Dallas where there was another
red carpet and more screaming and bodyguards
and more interviews and then many thousands
of people who, get this, Hank, wanted to wish
you a good morning.
Crowd: Good morning Hank it's Tuesday!
John [voiceover]: I was so grateful to have
this time to see so many nerdfighters and
to talk about the movie with the actors who
helped make it so special, but I also felt
really disconnected.
Like, with all these people from the outside
paying attention to us, I felt really self-conscious
as a nerdfighter, like it was hard for us
to be a community together, which is what
I love most about nerdfighteria.
And I was feeling pretty bummed out about
it AND THEN
So Hank during these events people could ask
questions and a young woman named Caroline
came up and introduced herself and talked
about how she's found The Fault in Our Stars
helpful as she lives with lymphoma.
She was pretty emotional as we talked and
so was I and so was the cast and then suddenly
thousands of people in the crowd began chanting
her name.
Crowd: Caroline!
Caroline!
John: I realized Hank that even if we're gonna
be scrutinized for a while by people who don't
know if nerdfighters fight for or against
nerds, nerdfighteria is still nerdfighteria.
I realized the community has never really
been about us, Hank.
It's been about having big conversations around
big questions and lifting up people who need
it.
So I want to say thank you nerdfighters from
Miami to Dallas and everywhere in between
for welcoming new people but also sticking
together.
Thank you for lifting each other up and for
decreasing suck and for increasing awesome.
When I am very far from home and feel very
disconnected from my real life, you guys help
me to feel like I am not so far from home
after all.
So thank you, I love you.
Not you Hank, everyone else, all the other
people.
Actually, you know what Hank?
God help me, I even love you.
By the way Hank, congrats on your album being
a huge hit on the iTunes charts, it's so great
everyone get it.
Hank, I will see you on Friday when I will
be hoooome!
Ohhhuhh.
DFTBA